hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by trade and
i'm going to be starting a new series
at your request that we've appropriately
named ask
abby i will be answering a handful or
two of your burning
nutrition questions and to me this is
really a good chance for me to cover
a wide range of nutrition related topics
but all
based specifically on your requests
so if you have a nutrition question that
wouldn't require an entire
video to unpack leave it for me below
for an upcoming episode and if you like
this format
give it the thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe and ring that little bell
so you never miss out on a video now
before we get into today's video i want
to talk about my
favorite food group coffee you
all know i love coffee and by the time
you're watching this
i will be a mom of two so yeah
coffee is pretty much key but
if you struggle with finding the perfect
coffee for you you are going to
love love love trade the way trade works
is that they source coffee from the
nation's best roasters to compile over
400
different ethically sourced coffees
you'll fill out an online survey about
your likes
and dislikes and how you prepare your
coffee like espresso
or drip and then they match you with
your perfect
dream coffee i am all about
customization
and i love trying new coffees whenever
i'm at a boutique coffee shop
so this is literally my kind of program
not to mention the prices are really
reasonable and they deliver
right to my door however often i need it
you know i'm shooting this before baby
comes but you can
bet i will be needing frequent
deliveries postpartum
then you can rate your matches so that
trade can continue to match you
with coffee that you will love in the
future so if you are a coffee lover like
me
you're going to want to click the link
in the description below
because trade is giving the first 100
people who click
on that link below 30 off of your first
coffee
yay coffee okay so before we get started
of course
my general disclaimer here that the
information in this video is for
entertainment
and educational purposes only and you
should always
speak to a health care provider about
your unique health care needs
all right so let's get into our
questions dear abby
should i consume protein before or after
a workout
i've heard people saying one or the
other and i'm confused as heck
what should i eat before and after a
workout generally speaking
should be carbs protein fats combination
help okay so great question
so it really depends on how close you're
eating to when you're going to be
working out and
since i'm not a sports dietitian
specialist
i consulted with my colleague chelsea
cross for this one to provide some
feedback
and a bit of practice based evidence so
let's start with
pre-workout snacks now before any kind
of short and fast
hit style cardio heavy workout you're
going to want to focus on
fast acting carbs and a bit of protein
but
something ideally a little lower in
fiber which can cause digestive distress
and may potentially slow down the
delivery of that energy
when you really need it so think like a
banana and maybe a little protein powder
or rice cake with some greek yogurt some
people are
bothered by fat in their pre-workout as
it can
impact digestion and absorption but
others find that they need that staying
power
so this is definitely more of a personal
thing and will really depend on your
specific workout
and your metabolism now for slow
longer steady state cardio like going on
a hike that lasts over an hour
or doing like a heavy strength training
session
you'll want to have a balanced
pre-workout snack so something with some
protein
and some long-lasting complex carbs and
even a bit of fat is okay for some
people
just to help provide that long-lasting
fuel
so this could be some full-fat greek
yogurt with fruit
it could be a shake with fruit and
protein powder
or some powdered protein batter on toast
etc
the truth is you don't actually have to
be too particular about this one
so just choose a snack that feels good
now for
post workout we used to think that you
had this
really really narrow anabolic window
after working out
like 30 minutes when your muscles were
most susceptible to accepting protein
repairing the damage that was done in
exercise and growing
we were taught that if you didn't have a
protein shake within
30 minutes your workout was essentially
wasted this is even something that i was
taught by a lot of dietitians a while
back
what we now know is that we actually
have a much more broad window to get
something
in for optimal nutrition one study from
2017 suggested
that if nutrients are consumed four to
six hours
around a workout that alone would
suffice
the only exception is if training is
done fasted because
studies do suggest that muscle protein
breakdown is significantly
raised post-workout and if there's no
fuel in the tank at all
the research supports having a
post-workout meal
immediately too soon after the
completion of your exercise
another coinciding study also done in
2017
supported the fact that eating within
two hours after working out
delivers the best benefits so when you
do eat
you'll want to have a combination of
protein and carbs to help repair
that muscle damage and replenish
glycogen stores respectively
so this could be some like tuna on bread
it could be an egg scramble with veggies
and toast
some pita and hummus etc it's also ideal
to keep your fat intake lower after your
workout
and focus on having the bulk of your fat
at other meals and snacks throughout the
day
this is simply because fat can slow down
the absorption of carbs and protein
not to mention can impact digestion if
consumed
too closely to working out but again
really
everybody is so unique so fat may impact
some people
much more than it does others okay folks
next question
dear abby let's talk about fruit sugar
should we fear it
and how much is too much no you don't
need to
fear it we don't have official
guidelines on how much fruit or
natural sugar is too much per se what we
do know
is that most health authorities
recommend limiting added
or free sugars to 10 percent of total
calories
but free sugars are things like honey
maple syrup
candy sugar etc so basically sugar
that's not naturally bound up with
fibers
or protein or fat to help slow down its
absorption
fruit on the other hand is not only
packed with antioxidants
and minerals but is also a good source
of fiber
and we know that both fiber and
antioxidants
have really important disease fighting
benefits
as for the fruit limits itself most
nutritional guidelines suggest sticking
to
two to four servings of fruit per day
for adults
and in my opinion the reason for this
recommendation
is less to do with blood sugar concerns
and more to do with fruits just
displacing vegetables
which are also really important in fact
one city found that when consuming whole
fruit so
not fruit juice it actually had very
little impact on blood sugar levels
because of its fiber and polyphenol
content
both of which have been shown to help
improve blood sugar control
so personally i believe in balance first
and i don't think that you need to limit
yourself to two or four servings of
fruit necessarily
as long as it's not displacing other
important foods in your diet
okay next so dear abby
what are some things to watch out for
when you're choosing plant-based
milks there are so many non-dairy milk
options on the market now
and obviously taste and texture is an
important consideration
some of us will like soy milk others
will like almond milk etc
but there are other things that you
might want to look out for as well
so first of all you'll want to check out
the nutrition panel and the ingredient
list
i recommend choosing an option that is
unsweetened
because some non-dairy milks have 10 or
more grams of added sugar
per cup and i would wait rather people
be able to control the amount of sugar
in their drinks
by adding sweetener at their discretion
you'll also want to find one that's
fortified with calcium
b12 and vitamin d which makes it more
comparable to
dairy milk and also ideally one with
higher amounts of protein
so a lot of nut based coconut rice or
oat milk for example
will be pretty low in protein maybe a
gram per serving
but something like soy milk or pea milk
will have
higher amounts now ingredient wise a lot
of non-dairy milks will have additives
and thickeners like guar gum or
carrageenan which really helps to
prevent the solids and the water from
separating
i know that these are super
controversial so i'm going to keep it
really short
but if you do want a whole video on
additives and thickeners
let me know and i will add it to my list
so
guar gum is a binding agent that's high
in soluble fiber
so it actually may help promote satiety
and regulate blood sugar the main thing
to flag however
is that large amounts can obstruct the
digestive system
but since the fda heavily regulates how
much gore gum can be added to a food
the worst you'll likely see is a bit of
gas diarrhea
bloating and cramps full blockages
aren't really a concern carrageenan on
the other hand comes from
red seaweed and some researchers have
presented animal research on it having
harmful effects on the gi tract
but then equally respected researchers
have refuted this science
and suggests that there's no reason to
ban it as a food additive
so i would say that because the research
isn't very clear
if you have a sensitive gut or ibs you
may want to look for a non-dairy milk
without these emulsifiers
just to be safe as for environmental
concerns
compared to cow's milk soy and oat milk
use
far less water land and produce less
carbon emissions
and while rice and almond are often
called out for being water hogs
they're still considered more
environmentally friendly than
cow's milk so to recap if you're going
dairy free
i recommend looking for a non-dairy milk
that is unsweetened
fortified with d c and ideally b12
one without emulsifiers if your gut is
sensitive
one that tastes good to you and one that
is environmentally friendly
especially if you drink a lot of it i
honestly switch things up and kind of go
through phases that are largely based on
flavor
right now as strange as it seems i've
been mixing
unsweetened cashew milk with a little
bit of chocolate oat milk in my lattes
but other days i use straight up
unsweetened almond milk and
that's kind of what i do so choose one
that works best for you
all right next dear abby how much
protein do
you actually need oh this
is a controversial topic and also a
really hard one to answer straight up
because obviously everybody's needs are
just so
variable and different if you look at
the recommended daily allowance or rda
for protein we're looking at 0.8
grams per kilogram so if i were to weigh
150 pounds
that would mean just 55 grams of protein
that's literally a chicken breast but
that's also pretty much the bare minimum
and most recommendations are much higher
to account for greater levels of
physical activity
as well as optimal body composition and
satiety
when i spoke to chelsea cross she told
me that a lot of people are scared to
get too much protein
but the research repeatedly suggests
that higher intakes
do not adversely affect kidney function
or bone health
in normal healthy adults so as far as
both of us are concerned
0.8 grams per kilogram is not adequate
to sustain muscle mass
for anyone who exercises or is trying to
manage their weight
but let's talk about some of the various
numbers and recommendations
that you might see floating around so in
2009
the academy of dietetics dietitians of
canada and american college of sports
medicine
all suggested that individuals who do 10
or more hours of vigorous endurance
training weekly
would need 1.2 to 1.4 grams per kilogram
and those who are training for strength
would need 1.4 to 1.8 grams per kilogram
another authority the national academy
of sports medicine
said that weight training athletes would
need 1.5 to
2 grams per kilogram per day and finally
a 2018 paper from the journal of
international society
of sports nutrition recommended 1.6
grams per kilogram
for muscle building so clearly lots of
different numbers
and it really comes down to your unique
needs and your unique
goals but now let's look at some of the
specific research for specific
populations well for muscle building
mass
in postmenopausal women one study
suggested that muscle strength improved
in women who are consuming a minimum of
1.2 grams per kilogram per day
in middle-aged adults trying to lose
weight research found that those who
consumed at least
1.34 grams per kilogram lost
more weight than those who ate the same
amount of calories
but lower amounts of protein in athletes
who are attempting
fat loss a protein intake of 1.8 to 2
grams per
kilogram has been shown to promote
weight loss while minimizing muscle loss
and research on fit young people has
found that ranges between
1.6 to 1.8 grams per kilogram
are ideal for body composition but that
anything beyond that
does not confer any additional benefits
so
what number is it abby well i don't
believe there is
one firm number for everyone i did ask
my colleague chelsea cross what she
recommends based on her own clinical
experience
working with the population for whom
protein is very important
she said she sticks to 0.8 to 1 gram per
pound of body weight
or 1.8 to 2.2 grams per kilogram of body
weight
with 1.6 grams per kilogram being the
minimum
for normal healthy adults her rationale
for aiming a bit higher is that
while excess protein may not promote
muscle protein synthesis
higher protein diets have been shown to
be more effective
and favorable for weight management
because they're just more satiating
and support metabolic muscle mass hey
guys just a little update from
postpartum life
as i was re-watching this in editing i
did have a thought that
i really should have included my own
professional opinion
even though sports nutrition really
isn't my area of expertise
but i want to clarify that i think most
average joes
probably don't need that much protein i
mean it's important for me to reiterate
that chelsea does
work largely with a population
interested in fitness and body
composition
which is really what informs her
recommendations at large
but if this isn't a priority for you
then
getting up to these numbers is likely
unnecessary
1.6 grams per kilogram is twice the rda
minimum recommendation so obviously
there is a wide range of appropriate
protein intakes
depending on your unique goals i also
want to add that unless you're an
athlete or
do have specific nutrition goals you
don't ever need to be counting grams of
protein
so as a general rule of thumb i suggest
aiming to fill about a quarter of your
plate with protein
about the size of the palm of your hand
and then aiming for at least
some protein at most snacks to help
boost up the satiety factor
bottom line this is not a
one-size-fits-all
model some people will just feel better
consuming
more or less protein depending on their
activity
and their metabolism so if you really
want to know the best amount of protein
for you
i really suggest working with a
dietitian not relying on
online calculators or even youtube
videos like this one to determine
your unique needs okay back to pregnant
abby
dear abby is the whoosh effect
during weight loss backed up by any
scientific literature
okay so if you haven't heard of the
woosh effect
it's essentially the idea that if you're
following a diet
one day you wake up and whoosh the
weight is gone
it's kind of like a massive breakthrough
in a weight loss plateau
so this is often talked about with
respect to the keto diet
but some people also find that it occurs
with other weight loss
diets as well now the idea behind this
is that when you start a diet your fat
cells
start to lose fat and that fat is
apparently replaced with water
and then one day whoosh that water's
flushed out into the toilet
and the fat cells allegedly collapse and
you drop
a ton of weight that's a theory anyways
the truth is
i searched and i searched and i searched
and i asked every single dietitian in
all of my practice groups
and there is no evidence that fat is
replaced with water when you lose weight
what we do know is that when you put
yourself in a caloric deficit for long
enough
the triglycerides in your cells are
broken down into carbon dioxide
and water you exhale the carbon dioxide
and you would pee breathe or sweat out
the water
specifically when it comes to keto we
also do see some
rapid weight loss at the start of a
program because you end up draining your
glycogen stores
aka your carb stores and for every one
gram of carbs
you hold on to about three to four grams
of water
so when you drain those carb stores you
reduce water retention
and that weight loss results in a lot of
the early
weight loss on keto now i can appreciate
the anecdotal evidence of the woosh
effect
is really powerful stuff and that even
coaches and fitness professionals
swear that they do see this whoosh-like
effect on the scale
after a weight loss stall but there's no
scientific way to explain this
as it relates to fat cells filling up
with water
and therefore it's likely that the
rationale for breakthroughs in weight
loss plateaus
are highly individual some alternative
hypotheses
is that it may be related to depleted
carb stores
hormonal shifts or your body just
adjusting to a lower caloric level
after it was fighting to maintain its
set point for so long
but ultimately we really don't have any
research on the woosh effect
or any of these other alternative
hypotheses to fully explain
why some people may experience this
phenomenon
all right next dear abby what is the
fine line between intermittent fasting
and disordered eating very good
question so good i want to hear from my
colleagues so
i posed this to one of my dietitian
practice groups and we all had such
an interesting discussion a lot of rds
said that there was no line
and that any restrictive diet was
disordered in nature
i tend to think it really depends on the
person
and how the diet impacts their life and
this could be applied not just to
intermittent fasting but really
to any intentional weight loss diet here
are some things to consider when
determining if a diet or way of eating
is unhealthy for you and your
relationship with food
ask yourself these questions is this
diet allowing you to get
everything you need both nutritionally
and emotionally
does this diet interfere with your
enjoyment of life or daily activities
do you feel stress or anxiety if you
break the rules
or you don't see the progress that
you're looking for does breaking your
diet throw you into even more
restrictive and panicked thinking
or can you just pick it up back where
you left off whenever you see fit
does this diet feel like it's become
part of your identity
and your worth and your character and
all of those things are bound up in your
ability to stick to the rules
is this diet feeling like punishment
because you hate your body or because
you love your body and just feel
better making these changes i genuinely
believe that there are a lot of
non-punishing reasons to try a keto diet
or intermittent fasting
or low fat diet etc if it benefits one's
physical
and emotional health it really comes
down to intentions
and how this way of eating makes you
feel about your body
food and your self-worth all right next
dear abby does vitamin c really
strengthen the immune system
okay so since i was a little girl every
time my dad would feel a cold coming on
he would literally down a bottle of
vitamin c tablets
vitamin c is a powerful antioxidant that
helps immune cells function
and it also helps to support physical
barriers like epithelial cells in your
skin
which protect you from pathogens and
while over a hundred animal studies
have found that vitamin c
supplementation can help prevent
infections by microorganisms does this
apply to humans well in a 2013 cochrane
review
it was found that people who already had
symptoms of a cold
did not get any benefit from vitamin c
though some studies suggest that
megadoses may help to reduce the
duration
we also need more research on that
the review also found that adults who
take vitamin c
regularly can expect eight percent
shorter colds
and maybe less severe symptoms while
athletes who take vitamin c regularly
are fifty percent less likely to catch a
cold than athletes who don't
another 2018 meta-analysis with nine
trials
found that vitamin c could shorten colds
and reduce symptoms
but that this meta-analysis was a third
of the size of the cochlear view
so it's not necessarily considered as
strong of evidence
bottom line supplementing regularly with
vitamin c
may help shorten the duration of a cold
and maybe even help prevent them in
athletes
but if you start taking it when you're
already sick
you're probably out of luck so
officially i don't like to say that
vitamin c
or really any one supplement boosts your
immune system
but it may help to support your immune
system
through its powerful antioxidant
properties okay and
last question for today's video dear
abby
do collagen supplements actually do
anything
very good question because man i am just
waiting for that postpartum hair loss to
kick in
and i am not looking forward to it
but collagen is one of the most abundant
proteins in the body
and makes up 80 of our skin
and not surprisingly as we age our
bodies naturally start producing
less collagen and that's why my friends
we have botox
but collagen supplements are found as
hydrolyzed collagen aka collagen
peptides which are
broken down to make it easier for the
body to absorb gelatin
which is partially broken down into
amino acids and as
raw or undenatured where the protein is
left
intact let's talk about some of the
alleged claims
starting with skin health now research
suggests that taking collagen
supplements for
several months can help to improve
wrinkles
and roughness in skin and reduce some of
the common signs of aging
one study in middle aged women found
that taking 2.5 grams
of hydrolyzed collagen daily for 8 weeks
reduced wrinkle volume
by 20 percent now another study found
that taking 2.5 grams of another brand
for 12 weeks reduced wrinkle depth by 27
and increased skin hydration by 28
sounds great yes but keep in mind that
these studies were funded by the
companies themselves
so it would be so great to see some more
third party testing
and some more randomized control trials
next let's talk about
hair so the research in this area is
limited
but one industry-funded double-blind
randomized control trial found that
15 healthy women with self-perceived
thinning hair
who are given a marine based collagen
supplement experienced subjective
improvements in hair volume sculpt
coverage
and thickness after 90 days as for nails
i wasn't able to find more than just one
study that used a brand of collagen
peptides on
25 participants but it found that it
promoted an increase in 12
nail growth rate and a decrease in 42
percent
in broken nails so while these study
results may seem really promising
there are a few really important red
flags to note
one the sample sizes are typically
really small
two they're funded by the product
manufacturers and
three these products often have various
ingredients
so it is hard to know exactly if it's
the collagen specifically
playing a beneficial role next let's
talk about joint health
so collagen type 2 is found in cartilage
which
is that cushioning that we have between
our joints we do have
industry funded research to suggest that
certain brands
can help to reduce joint pain stiffness
and disability in people with
osteoarthritis
by up to 38 but a systematic review of
the literature suggested
that the impact that it may have on
joint pain is small
at best so it's hard to know how
meaningful these results are to patients
in this grand scheme of everything what
about bones
well bones are made largely up of type 1
collagen
so it makes sense that consuming more
collagen may help to protect against
osteoporosis while most studies have
been conducted on animals
one human study on post-menopausal women
found that taking a brand of hydrolyzed
collagen
for a year increased bone density by
three to seven percent
bottom line collagen supplements may
help with a
wide range of ailments and it
theoretically
does make sense that they should but i
don't think that we have
a lot of really strong non-industry
funded research
yet to conclusively say that they make a
significant impact
also even if we did keep in mind that
the supplement world
isn't well regulated so i always suggest
looking
up your supplement brand on a
third-party testing website
like labdoor.com to see how your
supplement brand ranks
for purity and contaminants and that is
all for me today folks
thank you again to trade for sponsoring
this video if you liked it
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below with any of your
burning nutrition related questions
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and i will see you next time on abby's
kitchen
bye
you